Welcome back everyone
Maximum effort
It looks like we're getting the Deadpool
Corps
during Deadpool 3,
so we'll break it all down.
they're going to be
a ton of different cameos in the movie
as part of the Deadpool kills
the Fox Marvel
Universe storyline, like Wolverine,
the X-Men are just part of it.
Like, that's just the beginning.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes
because it is only going to get crazier
and crazier.
The movie will be a little bit
more like what people expected from Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness
when they announced
it was going to be a big multiverse movie,
a bunch of X-Men stuff
happening during it.
been doing a couple of reports
recently this past week
about which members of the Deadpool corps
will be in the movie because it's a lot
like the Spider forged from the Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse movie
or beyond the Spider-Verse
or the Thor Corps from Secret Wars,
the Council of Kangs, the Council
of Reeds, basically a multiverse team
made up of a bunch of different versions
of Deadpool from alternate universes.
Early on, when they started revealing
footage and details from Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine,
his yellow suit from the comics,
the eighth Universe,
the X-Men coming back,
they started posting footage of them
on the Void Planet from the Loki series.
I assumed there would be more Easter eggs
and references they borrow from Loki.
And they also did a giant team up
like this multiverse.
Loki is led by President Loki during that
not expecting to see alligator Deadpool
or anything like that.
But they will have crazy
versions of Deadpool
the difference with what they did
on the Loki series though,
is that all the different Loki's
were meant to be
so self-interested and backstabbing
that they weren't really a team so much.
Everyone betrayed each other
at the drop of a hat.
till alligator
Loki bit his hand off in the new main.
Loki. The others escaped from the bunker.
So if you're doing something
as crazy as that, it makes sense.
They try something similar with Deadpool
because that was supposed to be
even more ridiculous than Loki
they just make a bunch of the versions
of Deadpool way, way crazier
there was even a rumor early on that
they do a version of Galactus pool,
like a version of Deadpool
that became Galactus,
who isn't even fully explained that
well in the comics itself.
like it's just a version of Deadpool
who turned into Galactus at some point.
No, no, no.
How true that is him being in the movie,
because you kind of need to do a version
of regular Galactus
before you do a joke version of Galactus
for casual audiences to get it.
It was kind of like this.
During the first Deadpool movie,
there are a lot of Easter eggs
and references,
but I think for the most part,
if you didn't know the Deadpool character
and you went into that first
or even the second Deadpool movie,
you could still get most of the jokes.
regular Galactus is supposed to be
in the new Fantastic Four movie,
but that's not going to release till after
Deadpool three, So I'm not expecting
a bunch of Galactus stuff to happen
until that new Fantastic Four movie.
But there is a rumor that Antonio Banderas
might wind up playing the character,
which would be pretty interesting.
the actual Deadpool Corps was created
by the main 616 Deadpool.
Even though Ryan Reynolds is from the Fox
Marvel universe,
he is meant to be the main version
of the character and eventually
he'll will travel to the 616 universe.
The MCU basically
there'll be people arguing
about that, like, Oh, the 616 universe
isn't meant to be the MCU.
Even though
Kevin Foggy said that multiple times,
they'll probably clear a lot of that stuff
up when Secret Wars happens
and they do a bit of a soft
reboot and change things
and they'll just start calling the main
MCU 616 definitively,
the reason why the team formed in
the comics is because Deadpool was chosen
by this cosmic being
called the contemplating to top another
cosmic entity called the awareness
who is consuming the entire multiverse.
does that not sound familiar?
That sounds a lot like what
Elias was doing on the Loki series the
he who remains version of Kang said
he could literally consume
entire timelines, entire universes.
And during that he explained
that he used it to destroy
all the different timelines
in the previous Kang Multiverse war
except for his own, to get rid
of all the different King variants.
Then he said it to the void planet
to just consume anything.
The TVA would send their imprint
basically like a galactic trash
compactor for anything
that might cause a Nexus event.
so because the TVA is so important.
During Deadpool three,
it seems like Deadpool and Wolverine
get pruned at some point by them
sent to the Void planet.
most of the footage we've seen of
the two of them
is fighting each other to a standstill
because they both have healing factors.
So the fight just goes on and on and on in
front of the remains of the 20th Century
Fox logo, which would have also
been pruned in some other universe
that's meant to be more of a meta joke
about Disney buying Fox
and rendering a lot of the old Fox stuff
obsolete, so to speak, even though
that's not exactly
what's happening in present day.
Like Kevin, Foggy
is recasting a lot of the X-Men,
a lot of the Fox Marvel characters,
like Fantastic Four characters.
But. He's bringing a lot of them back
to Cameo during Deadpool three
and then eventually Secret Wars
to give them one last big hurrah
and basically
just say that they all come
from different universes.
So in the main 616 universe,
he'll recast versions,
but the other versions will still exist
in other universes.
the other thing
a lot of you realize too
that we don't know
when this is actually happening
in the timeline.
If Deadpool three happens before Loki
season one or like after Loki season two
because in the new rebooted timeline,
there's like a brand new version of Kang
that reigns over the TVA.
Like, things are completely changed,
so there might not be a version of a Life
on the Void planet
when they get stuck there
the very first version of the Deadpool
Corps team was main Deadpool
head pool lady,
Deadpool dogpool and Kidpool.
And it seems like
since they're supposedly doing Kidpool
in multiple variants of Deadpool,
that's why I think everyone thinks
that they're doing Deadpool Corps.
it'll be a little bit like them
forming in the comics where in the movie
Ryan Reynolds just pulls a bunch of
versions of Deadpool together to team up.
And it's also a bit like that
joke in Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania,
where there were
a bunch of versions of Scott Lang.
they even had the bit
about the regular Scott Lang,
who never left his job at Baskin-Robbins
and never became Ant-Man.
Supposedly they're going to do something
similar in the Deadpool three movie
where one of the versions of Deadpool
is this like
got totally regular Ryan Reynolds
wearing a Wrexham AFC jersey.
maybe they'll just say that
version of Deadpool
is just like real life Ryan Reynolds
and it gets super meta with it.
like he's
married to a version of Blake Lively.
He also has a couple of daughters
like Ryan Reynolds does in real life.
the whole thing with Wrexham.
AFC is if you haven't been keeping up
with Ryan Reynolds in real life, he's
been super busy outside of making movies
the past couple of years.
He bought a ton of businesses.
They're all doing gangbusters.
Like he is an amazing pitch man.
most people know him
from all of his gin ads or his
cell phone business, Mint mobile.
but one of the businesses
that he bought the past couple of years
was the Wrexham Football Club
with Rob McElhenney from Always Sunny in.
The two of them
spent the last couple of years
turning the club around
and now they're doing amazing.
That's why you see him
at the Wrexham games all the time.
they also made a documentary TV
show about it called Welcome to Wrexham.
so it makes sense that he tried
to find a way to get Wrexham into Deadpool
three somehow.
I don't know what they're actually doing.
Lady Deadpool, Dog poo or head ball,
but it makes sense
that they would just have a bunch
a bunch of background Deadpool
so there could be a ton
of different versions from the comics.
the only one I think we know for
sure is a version of Kidpool.
A good example.
That will be the clip
that Ryan Reynolds posted of his younger
costar doing a Deadpool monologue
a couple of years ago.
This is meant to be one of the
monologues from Deadpool two.
so imagine a version of that.
But with him wearing a Deadpool suit
and mask in the comics, kid
pool was meant to be from a universe
where a child version of Wade
Wilson joined Professor X's Mutant School.
But it was called s saviors orphanage
for troubled boys.
They had a similar joke to that
in the first Deadpool movie with the bar
where he and the other mercenaries
hung out there were also reports
that Emma Corrin would be the main villain
of the movie as part of the larger
A3 eight universe plot
Now it seems like she's actually playing
Cassandra Nova,
who is the evil twin of Professor X.
That's the super deep cut for the X-Men
comics and for the recent Deadpool movies.
during Deadpool two?
One of the main villains was Juggernaut
Professor X's brother.
So it's just like another member
of Professor X's family, Cassandra
Nova has a really crazy backstory,
so I'll explain her.
she's a relatively newer character
from the recent new X-Men
run in the early 2000.
That was Grant Morrison's run.
So no surprise.
Deadpool one,
to borrow from one of the comic book
Masters, is a great run
if you haven't read it.
they even borrowed a little bit
from that run for X-Men Dark Phenix.
the costumes
that the X-Men team is wearing during
that are from that new X-Men run.
Her full name, though, is Cassandra Nova.
Xavier because Charles Xavier
in as you would expect
from Grant Morrison,
her backstory is totally nuts.
like, how did Professor X have a twin
that we just learned about in the twins?
He explained that
because Professor X was born so powerful,
his genetic potential was so great
when he was in his mother's womb growing,
it caused the creation of a fraternal
twin to form from the living embodiment
of Professor X's antiseptic,
this cosmic form that took shape
because he was so powerful.
they explain that the
she r have this concept
saying that each person has an opposite
or an anti form of themselves that exist
cosmically out there in the universe,
but usually just this formless
cosmic energy that never takes shape,
especially for people who aren't
that powerful like normal humans.
But because Professor X was so powerful
even in his mother's womb,
his antics Self was able to take
for sort of like latch on to him
and use that to take form
and become his fraternal twin.
later taking the name Cassandra
Nova Xavier.
now. Emma Corrin doesn't look anything
like Patrick Stewart, even younger
Patrick Stewart But I think they'll just
kind of wave their hands at that.
when they were growing in the womb,
Professor X was so powerful that he
unconsciously became aware of her,
his evil anti self, and tried to kill her
with his mutant powers
like kill his twin in the womb
the event was so crazy
it caused his mother to suffer
a miscarriage
when she gave birth to both them.
And they believe that only Professor
X survived the birth.
But Cassandra Nova,
having powers equal to that of Professor
X was able to survive as a lump of cells
hiding in the walls of the building.
Yes, this is right.
Grant Morrison actually wrote this slowly,
creating a body for herself over decades
until eventually she was able to emerge
looking just like Professor X,
but super evil, super pissed off
and looking for revenge against him.
they'll be working on the movie
for a while.
So I'll do more Deadpool videos
when we learn more about what's going on.
If we get more footage,
let me know if you have any questions
about the characters
or any bonus video requests
there'll be some Easter eggs
and crossover references happening
during Loki Season two,
But I'm not expecting to see Deadpool
show up
during the Loki season two episodes
or Loki to show up during Deadpool three.
Look, there's already
so many characters in Deadpool three,
so we'll see about that Loki.
Season two starts in October,
right after the episodes finish.
I'm doing episode videos
for both of those series,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss those.
Click here for my Ahsoka Episode
4 video and click here to read about
all the Deadpool three cameos.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and maximum effort!